well good afternoon everyone and thank
you all for joining us today at Ramstein
we've just concluded the eighth Ukraine
defense contact group meeting
and it was great to start the new year
by
deepening our coordination as we work
together for
Ukraine's self-defense
President Biden has said
this is a decisive decade for the world
and this is a decisive moment for
Ukraine's struggle to defend itself
so this contact group will not slow down
we're going to continue to dig deep and
based upon the progress that we've made
today
I'm confident that Ukraine's partners
from around the globe
are determined to meet this moment
the United States remains committed to
leading in this coordinated effort
and this morning I was pleased to
announce
another major round of U.S security
assistance
designed to meet Ukraine's urgent
Battlefield requirements
in this 2.5 billion dollar package
is one of our largest yet
it helps Ukraine meet its air defense
needs
with additional nay Sam's munitions
and eight Avenger air defense systems
in this package also helps
tackle Ukraine's urgent needs for armor
and combat vehicles
it includes 59 additional Bradley
infantry fighting vehicles
and 90 Striker armored personnel
carriers
53 M reps
and 350 up armored Humvees
and it will provide thousands around
thousands more rounds of artillery
now we were honored to hear this morning
from president zielinski of Ukraine
let me also thank several other Brave
Ukrainian leaders for joining us today
and that includes
my good friend Minister Alexi reznikov
the minister of defense
and Lieutenant General Moy shook
the deputy chief of Defense
their presentations gave us a firsthand
of count
of what Ukraine's military and citizens
are facing
today's meeting focused on Ukraine's
needs for air defense and armor
we also pushed hard on how to
synchronize those donations
and turn them into fully operational
capabilities
and that means
every step from donation
to training to maintenance and then to
sustain it
we also focused hard on how our
Collective and and individual training
efforts would be prosecuted
so
as you heard President Biden recently
announced the latest U.S training
initiative
and it builds on U.S programs to train
Ukrainian troops dating back to 2014.
other countries are stepping up with
their own initiatives and many are
joining the European Union's
military assistance mission
and Meanwhile we're also continuing to
strengthen our defense industrial bases
through the work of the national
armaments directors
under the auspices of this contact group
and all of these efforts underscore how
much we've deepened our cooperation
since the contact group began last April
our work shows how much nations of
Goodwill can achieve when we work
together
and it shows our long-term commitment to
supporting Ukraine
against
Russia's unprovoked aggression
now as we saw again just days ago in
nepro
Russia continues its assault on
Ukraine's civilian and and critical
infrastructure
and Russia continues to bombard
Ukraine's cities with cruise missiles
and drones
but the Ukrainian people stand defiant
and strong
and Ukrainian troops are bravely
defending their country
and their fellow citizens
as Russia's cruelty deepens
the resolve of this contact group grows
and that's clear from the announcements
that we've heard today and I'll start
with air defense
countries have come forward with key
donations that will help protect Ukraine
skies and cities and citizens
in France and Germany and the UK
have all donated air defense systems to
Ukraine
and that includes a patriot battery from
Germany
and that's especially important coming
alongside our own contribution of a
patriot system
and the Netherlands is also donating
Patriot missiles and launchers and
training
meanwhile Canada has procured a nasam
system
in Associated Munitions for Ukraine
and so these air defense systems will
help save countless innocent lives
[Music]
we're also pushing hard to meet
Ukraine's requirements for tanks and
other armored vehicles
the UK has announced a significant
donation of Challenger 2 tanks for
Ukraine
this is the first introduction of
Western Maine battle tanks into Ukraine
may also commend our British allies for
for making this decision
and Sweden announced it's donating cd-90
infantry fighting vehicles
and an additional donation soon of
Archer howitzers
you've also heard inspiring and
important new donation announcements
from several other countries and and
that includes Denmark which will donate
19 howritters
in Latvia is donating more stingers and
helicopters and other equipment
and Estonia is providing Ukraine with a
significant new package of much needed
155 millimeter howitzers and munitions
now all of today's announcements
are are direct results of our work at
the contact group
and these important new commitments
demonstrate the ongoing resolve of our
allies and partners to help Ukraine
defend itself
because this isn't just about Ukraine's
security
it's also about European security
and it's about Global Security
it's about the kind of world
that we want to live in
and it's about the world that we want
our children and grandchildren to
inherit
the members of this contact group are
standing up
for a world where where rules matter
and where rights matter
and where sovereignty is respected
and where people can choose their own
path
free from tyranny and aggression
and I'm confident that this group
will remain United
and we'll continue to build momentum
we'll support Ukraine against Russian
aggression for the Long Haul
and we'll continue to work toward a free
and security rate Ukraine in a stable
and decent world
and with that let me turn it over to the
chairman for his comments
good afternoon everyone and thank you
secretary Austin for your leadership in
this uh eighth Ukrainian contact group
in support of Ukrainian freedom and
thanks as well to all the ministers and
the chauds the chiefs of defense that
we're here who represented 54 different
countries today
a special thank you also to Ukrainian
Minister defense uh rizikov and Deputy
Chief of Defense General moisick I had
recently had an opportunity to meet with
General zaluzny in Poland and uh General
moisick was here representing him they
all represent the exceptional bravery of
the Ukrainian Army and most importantly
the Ukrainian people this week after
meeting General zaluzi had an
opportunity to visit some of the
training in the mech infantry that we
are doing at grafenwehr here in a
training area in Germany also an
opportunity to do some coordination
meetings in Wiesbaden and then attended
the NATO Chad's military committee
meeting where all the members of all the
trods of NATO had an opportunity to meet
with one of the primary topics being
support to Ukraine and then of course
this week ending it today this week with
uh with the contact group I think that
over my 43 years in uniform this is the
most unified I've ever seen NATO and
I've dipped in and out of NATO over many
many years
the war has evolved over the last 11
months but the mission of this group
this contact group under General
Austin's leadership under secretary
Austin's leadership has remained the
same
we are effectively committed to support
Ukraine with capabilities to defend
itself against the illegal and
unprovoked Russian aggression
in the words of President Biden
secretary Austin and many other national
leaders
as much as it takes for as long as it
takes in order to keep Ukraine free
independent and sovereign
these contact group meetings play an
important role as we support Ukraine in
the defense of its territory and they
are a clear unambiguous demonstration of
the unity and resolve of the Allied
Nations
yesterday
as secretary Austin just mentioned
President Biden released our 30th
security assistance package signifying
our continued commitment to Ukraine this
package combined with our previous one
includes combined arms maneuver
capabilities with supporting artillery
equivalent to at least to combined arms
maneuver brigades or six Mech infantry
battalions
10 motorized infantry battalions
and four artillery battalions along with
a lot of other equipment this package
this U.S package along with the Allied
donations that were indicated today
signify our Collective resolve and our
commitment to Ukraine to protect their
population
from the indiscriminate Russian attacks
and to provide the armor necessary to go
on the offensive
to liberate russian-occupied Ukraine
additionally this week in Germany we
began Battalion and Brigade collective
training that I had an opportunity to
visit
at the combined house maneuver Training
Center
here in grafenville in support of
Ukrainian Army
that training in addition to the
equipment will significantly increase
ukrainian's capability to defend itself
and further Russian attacks
and to go on the Tactical and
operational offensive to liberate the
occupied areas
with the training that the United States
and our partners are doing
the ukrainians will advance their
command and control their tactics
techniques and procedures their ability
to integrate fires with maneuver and
they will more effectively synchronize
all of the combined arms in order to
execute maneuver-based operations
the support that we discussed today in
this contact group meeting the training
that we discussed today and the way
ahead
it's really an extension of what's been
going on since 2014. and today signifies
a very real and tangible difference in
the Ukraine's efforts to defend itself
International aggression where large
countries use military force to attack
small countries and change recognize
borders cannot be allowed to stand
eventually
President Putin Russia will realize the
full extent of their strategic
mascaculation
but until Putin ends this war his war of
choice
the nations of this contact group will
continue to support the defense of
Ukraine in order to uphold the
rules-based international order thank
you and I welcome your questions thank
you Mr secretary chairman our first
question will go to Utes from Ard
hello Mr Secretary of Defense my
question is many of us thought that
today we will have a breakthrough in the
discussion about heavy metal tanks
you didn't mention that at all we didn't
talk about Leo part 2 or everyone's
tanks so did you talk about that today
um I think you heard you may have heard
the German Minister of Defense say
earlier that they've not made a decision
on the provision of leopard tanks uh
we're really focused on
is making sure that
Ukraine has a capability uh that it
needs to be successful right now so we
have a window of uh opportunity here uh
you know between now and the spring when
I you know whenever they commence uh
their operation they're counter
offensive uh and that's not a long time
and we have to pull together the right
capabilities and you heard that the
chairman walk through some of these
substantial combat power that we and and
some of our allies have uh have offer
offered to provide
uh there are tanks in that uh in that uh
those offerings uh Poland for example it
continues to offer tanks and will
provide tanks in other countries will
offer some take capability as well I
don't have any announcements to make on
him once and you heard the uh the German
Ministry of Defense say that uh they've
not made a decision on leopards so
next question will go to Idris Ali
Reuters
uh Mr secretary over the past week a
number of European countries have
publicly pleaded with Germany to allow
the transfer of their tanks you may with
your German counterpart yesterday and
like you said today they still have not
made a decision are you um disappointed
in the German position and how can
Germany still be seen as a reliable Ally
given what is widely perceived as them
dragging their feet on something so
simple and for the chairman um
is there any prohibition on the use of
American weapons by the ukrainians in
Crimea currently and you've talked about
how this war like many others has to end
through a negotiated settlement is now
the time for the Russians and ukrainians
to come to the table to talk about that
um thanks Idris first let me say that uh
this isn't really about one single
platform
and so our goal and I think we've been
fairly successful at doing this and
bringing together capability
is to is to provide the capability that
Ukraine needs to be successful in the
near term and so you've heard us talk
about uh two battalions of uh Bradley uh
infantry fighting Vehicles very capable
platform
um
three battalions or a brigadeworth of uh
Strikers uh so you add that up that's
that's two brigades of combat power that
the U.S is providing along with enablers
and other things so you look at Sweden
providing a battalion of CV 90s that's
an armored personnel carrier the Germans
are providing Martyrs uh the uh the
polls are providing a battalion's worth
of uh mechanized capability you heard
the chairman highlight uh four
battalions of uh of artillery mechanized
artillery that's being provided so this
is a this is a very very capable package
and they you know if if uh if employed
properly uh it will it will enable them
to be successful now we're going to
ensure that we're doing everything
necessary to ensure that they have the
ability to employ it properly you heard
us talk about training additional
training that we're going to do this is
something that we haven't been able to
do in the past yes so you know as we
speak you know troops are being linked
up with uh Bradley infantry fighting
vehicles uh and they'll train for weeks
not only on just how to operate the
vehicles but also uh on how to properly
set conditions for maneuver and then
maneuver and then you know how to
exploit uh opportunities how to breach
obstacles uh so I think this will be a
really really capable package that we
put together and I really do believe
that it will enable the ukrainians to be
successful going forward so this is not
dependent upon a single platform now
this is uh this is a combined arms
effort that we brought together that I I
truly believe is going to provide them
the best opportunity for success
and there's the uh
on your first question uh typically
we're not going to discuss I don't
discuss either prohibitions or
permissions authorities on the use of
weapons Etc that's that goes towards
Rules of Engagement we don't typically
discuss those in in a public forum on
the second question
um President Biden uh president
zielinski and most of the leaders of
Europe have said that this war is likely
to end in a negotiation and and from a
military standpoint this is a very very
difficult fight uh this fight stretches
uh all the way from right now as the
front line goes from all the way from
car to keep down to kirison and the
significant fighting ongoing uh and it's
more or less a static front line right
this minute with the exception of Bak
moo and solidar with a significant
offensive action going on really from
both sides
the distance that for the United States
that's about from uh I guess Washington
DC to Atlanta so that is a significant
amount of territory and in that
territory uh are still remaining a lot
of Russian forces and Russian occupied
Ukraine so from a military standpoint I
still maintain that for this year it
would be very very difficult to
militarily eject the Russian forces from
all every inch of Ukrainian occupied or
Russian occupied Ukraine that doesn't
mean it can't happen doesn't mean it
won't happen but it'd be very very
difficult I think what can happen is a
is a continued defense stabilizing the
front I think it's possible to to
clearly do that and I think it's uh
depending on the delivery and training
of all of this equipment I do think it's
very very possible to for the ukrainians
to run a significant uh tactical or or
even operational level offensive
operation to liberate as much Ukrainian
territory as possible and then we'll
then we'll see where it goes but I do
think at the end of the day this war
like many wars in the past will end at
some sort of negotiating table and that
will be determined in terms of timing
but the leaders of both countries both
both Russia and and Ukraine uh President
Putin could end this war today it's he
started it it's his war of choice and he
could end it today uh because it's
turning into an absent catastrophe for
Russia massive amounts of casualties
lots of other damage to the to the
Russian military Etc uh so he should and
could in this war right now right today
thank you our next question will go to
Anson Stan zdf thank you very much Mr
secretary is Germany doing enough in
order to show real leadership in Europe
thank you
yes
but we can all do more in uh you know
the United States and every other member
of the UDC can can do more you know
Germany has contributed a lot to this uh
to this campaign uh you know from the
very beginning we we saw them uh cycle
in uh air defense capability uh the
gephards uh the Patriots most recently
Irish T
they've stepped up and offered to
provide the martyrs they will provide
those Martyrs and conduct the training
on those platforms uh and
um
we are training uh Ukrainian soldiers on
uh on maneuver and other things uh and
Specialty things uh here uh in Germany
as well so Germany's open continues to
open its doors and and make the training
areas uh and Facilities available for us
to continue to do the work that we need
to do and Germany is also training uh
troops and training uh Battalion and
Brigade headquarters so you know they
have a big ore in the water like the
rest of the contact group does uh and uh
and they're working hand in hand uh with
with uh with the rest of our colleagues
here so I think Edris asked me uh
earlier uh if
if if Germany uh was uh was a leader was
that the right question there you just
[Music]
oh yeah okay yeah they are reliable Ally
and they've been that way for for a very
very long time and I I truly believe
that they'll continue to be a reliable
Ally going forward uh not to mention uh
they have uh Germany is host to 39 000
of my troops and their families uh and
also 10 000 civilians here and and so
we've had a great relationship
throughout over the years and I will
continue to have that that great
relationship and Germany will continue
to exercise leadership going forward so
thank you our next question will go to
Dan lamothe Washington Post
evening gentlemen thanks for your time
today uh secretary Austin a number of
lawmakers and observers have said that
at this point it makes sense to send a
small number of Abrams Tanks if only to
encourage Germany to unlock the leopard
tanks that they have not sent is that
feasible and if not why not and for the
chairman police given the amount of
armor of the United States and allies
are sending at this point how confident
are you that they can put together a
coherent offensive in the coming months
to what extent uh to the extent you can
what that what what might that look like
and uh separately you just reference the
large number of casualties can you give
us any update on what you're seeing at
this point for casualties on both sides
thanks
um I think you heard a German uh
Minister of Defense say earlier today
that there's no linkage between
um
providing m1s and providing uh leopards
and I think he was pretty clear about
that so this notion of unlocking you
know I in in my mind is not it's not an
issue and more importantly in his mind
as well and in terms of providing
capability
what we uh in the in the department
always look at is you know providing
credible combat capability we we don't
do things uh to or employ
capabilities as a notion you know as a
as you know for for anything other than
providing credible combat uh capability
and that's where our Focus will be in
the in the future whatever we do
whatever we employ so
so Dan on the uh
in order to execute a successful
offensive operation at the Tactical
operational level which is really what
we're talking about here for the
ukrainians uh you've got to not only man
the unit which the ukrainians have the
Personnel but they have to be trained
and so they got to be married up with
equipment and then they got to be
trained
um and if you look at the weather and
terrain Etc
um you can see that you have a
relatively short window of time to
accomplish both those key tests so
that's very very challenging to do that
for all these different nations that
were here today to assemble all of the
equipment get it all synchronized get it
get the Ukrainian troops trained
Etc uh that'll be a very very heavy lift
so uh confident uh yes I think it can be
done uh but I think that it'll be a
challenge there's no question about it
so we'll see I don't want to predict one
way or the other but the Ukrainian
forces so far have executed at least two
and perhaps even more than that very
successful offensive operations one up
around car keys across in the Asheville
River in in over in to uh in in into uh
the Russian lines to the uh east of the
uh of card keep and then they've run a
very successful operation down in
kirison uh so it remains to be seen
about the equipment's getting married up
with the people people got to get
trained on the equipment and all that's
going to have to get shipped in into
Ukraine Etc all put together uh inside
of a coherent plan uh obviously General
zaluzzi and I and others have uh uh
discussed uh what his Visions are not in
executable level detail yet but uh he's
working on that and uh and we'll see
which way it goes uh in terms of uh
casualties
you know the numbers of casualties in
War are always suspect uh and and but I
would tell you that the Russian
casualties the last time I reported out
on it publicly I said it was well over a
hundred thousand uh I would say it's
significantly well over 100 000 now so
the Russians have suffered a tremendous
amount of casualties in their in their
military uh and and that includes the
regular military and also their
mercenaries in the Wagner group and
other type forces that are fighting with
the Russians they have really suffered a
lot now you saw that the Russians uh did
a call-up of uh called out I think
called up an immobilization uh 300 000 I
think they were able to get maybe 200
250 000 something in that range so
they're replacing their losses in terms
of Manpower but they have suffered a
huge amount uh Ukraine has also suffered
tremendously you know that uh there's a
significant amount of innocent civilians
that have been killed in as a result of
the Russian actions uh the Russians are
hitting civilian infrastructure uh
there's a significant amount of economic
damage significant amount damage to the
energy infrastructure and the Russian or
the Ukrainian military has suffered a
significant amount of casualties
themselves so this is a very very bloody
war and there's significant casualties
on both sides and this is why I say that
I think that uh sooner or later this is
going to have to get to a negotiating
table at some point uh in order to bring
this to a conclusion and that will have
to happen uh when the end state which is
a free Sovereign independent Ukraine
with its territory intact is met when
that day comes then people sit down and
negotiate into this but there's been a
huge amount of suffering on both sides
ladies and gentlemen that is all the
time we have available today Mr
Secretary General Millie thank you both
gentlemen this concludes our press
briefing thank you
so the U.S defense secretary Lord Austin
the speaking and
um the I forget his name U.S joint chief
of staff's Mark milley
um speaking there after that Ally
meeting in Ramstein in Germany and we
were waiting to hear what they were
going to say about tanks let's be to a
Europe correspondent Siobhan Robin she's
in Berlin she was obviously listening to
that and really in that initial speech
that Lloyd Austin gave no mention of
those tanks at all
yes that was really interesting wasn't
it both of those spokespeople the U.S
defense secretary and the joint Chief of
Staff really using their time to
underline the unity again that message
that was being made clear at the start
of the meeting being reiterated at the
end of it talking about the various
commitments that Partners in that
Coalition have made to support Ukraine
talking as well about support that
Germany has offered and underlining the
fact that Britain this week has
committed to sending 14 Challenger 2
tanks which will be the first of these
battle tanks to go into Ukraine from
Europe but as you say missing from both
of those speeches was a commitment by
Germany to unlock the leopard 2 tanks
and for people who aren't up to speed on
this essentially what a lot of focus has
been ahead of this meeting is that
Ukraine has been asking for several
hundred battle tanks there's been
General consensus across Europe that the
best ones to send would be these leopard
twos the problem is that Germany holds
the export license and until it gives
the go-ahead it can't send its own
leopard to stocks and nor can its allies
and that has been causing frustration
now what I thought was really
interesting was that while that wasn't
spoken about in the main speeches it was
the focus of of course the journalist
questions everyone asking what's going
on people asking really tough questions
is Germany a reliable Ally is it showing
that it can lead and stand in the
leadership role in Europe and the
Americans really backing the Germans
saying they are a reliable Ally that
they are leaders still and that everyone
can do more
um but I think what we need to take away
from is that potentially there has been
a little bit of progress on this and
that goes back to what the German
defense minister said in the last few
hours essentially saying that they
hadn't shut the conversation down
completely what they are asking is for
both themselves and their allies to look
at the stocks to do an inventory to see
where their tanks are how quickly can
they send them you know what sort of
conditions are they they and what sort
of training is needed and this is so the
if and it is an if in the future Germany
does either let their allies send the
tanks or it sends its own leopard two
tanks that they can do it quickly
because we've set it time and again but
if they make a massive announcement and
then it's a month or a Year's delay
before the first of these tanks arrive
in Ukraine it's totally pointless so
they need to be able to act quickly so
there has been a little bit of progress
and also I think the other thing that
seems to be interesting about the end of
this meeting is that at the beginning we
heard really frustrated statements from
countries including Poland who were
saying essentially if you don't give us
permission Germany you know what we
might just send these tanks anyway and
they seem to have rode back a little bit
and the defense minister of Poland
saying after the meeting that there's
been this Coalition that's going to be
made with 15 other defense ministers
who've spoken on the sidelines and
they're going to work together to try
and look at how these tanks can be sent
and he said that he thinks there will be
success in the future it seems like the
temp picture has been cooled down a
little bit everyone's got a little bit
calmer potentially I expect the US has
been saying behind the scenes everyone
needs to be United because really this
is what Russia wants it wants Ukraine's
allies to be divided it wants people to
say I don't want to send stuff it wants
people to say we've hit our red line and
that's what really Ukraine and the US
and all of the partners said can't
happen so the message coming out is the
tanks the conversation is ongoing but in
terms of support for Ukraine they are
all United on in ongoing support and for
as long as it takes okay Siobhan thank
you so much Siobhan Robbins then Berlin
well here in the glass box our
International Affairs editor Dominic
waghorn is with me and I want to pick up
on that point because it's really
interesting isn't it the language that
Lloyd Austin was using
um we are committed to supporting
Ukraine we have Collective resolve and
specifically the Germans are a reliable
Ally and they will continue to exercise
leadership yeah I mean effectively he's
he's papering over these cracks that are
emerging and have emerged at Ramstein
over this crucial issue of tanks and it
really gets the heart of the debates
that exists and has been going on for
some time between Ukraine and its
Western allies and amongst Western
allies of Ukraine as well and that is
how how sort of formidably do you press
the advantage against the Russians the
ukrainians say what is needed is a
knockout blow they need Putin needs to
be beaten resoundingly and decisively
otherwise he will Retreat to the same
kind of games he's been playing since
2014. they said the rest of the world
kind of forgets the fact that they've
been fighting an eight going on for
nine-year war against Russia and unless
Putin is is dealt and given a lesson
that he learns from he's going to carry
on with it so you could have the kind of
piece that Marley was talking about
there Mark milley was talking about
there being negotiated but they say you
know this could have been just a few
years later Russia goes back to what
it's doing now against that is this
reluctance among some countries in the
west to give of Ukraine what it says it
needs to deal with Russia decisively
because of the fear of Russian
escalation and ahead of this meeting we
heard from uh Medvedev Dimitri Medvedev
a key Putin crony again rattling the
nuclear saber saying that conventional
defeat could lead to nuclear war after
after the Ukraine war and and raising
that possibility of escalation and they
can't even say that that is just empty
taught but it is causing concern in the
west and that debate is coming to a head
over the issue of Tanks because if
you're Germany or America and you give
the Americans the Abram Abraham's M1
tank or in the German's case the leopard
tank then that could in their minds be
in America's case then the main
offensive capability the ukrainians are
using against Russia is American or if
it was Germans uh Germany's leopard two
tanks it would be German and that would
be seen the theories would be seen as
sufficient provocation to make this from
a Ukraine war again against Russia
backed by NATO into an overtly American
or German or NATO war against Russia so
the fear in the west is of escalation
and the ukrainians are saying that that
is leading to Too Much timidity and
reticence in terms of arming them
against Russia so what we've seen
effectively is a kind of decision to
delay this to kick it down the line
there's some kind of compromises Siobhan
was saying there some signs towards
progress towards some kind of agreement
over the battle tank but certainly no
decision today and I suppose the key
question really is if you're sitting in
the Kremlin facing decisions about
militarizing your economy sending
thousands tens of thousands more men to
the front is anything you're hearing
from Ramstein today going to deter you
well probably not what would have
deterred Putin made him think think
again would be the decision to send
European or American battle tanks into
this war and so far it's just British
tanks Challenger tanks on the way so 14
of them which won't be enough
to deter Russia so I think it will be
disappointing for the ukrainians
undoubtedly but they will be hoping that
Siobhan is right and that other
observers are right that this is there
are signs of progress that some kind of
compromise is being forged and
ultimately these key game-changing tanks
will be on the way to Ukraine